a stampede from police water cannon as
teargas once more filled the streets of
Hong Kong the main battleground was
Nathan Road Hong Kong's busiest
thoroughfare in the heart of Kowloon
popular with tourists who would have
struggled to recognize the place now as
petrol bombs were hurled by protesters
the vandalism was targeted Chinese owned
businesses were singled out a mobile
phone provider a branch who'd already
boarded up metal fences were unscrewed
to make barricades rocks torn up from
sidewalks were scattered across roads
once more police are firing teargas
slowly they been reclaiming this busy
thoroughfare
but the firing of teargas is upsetting
local people as a result another tense
confrontation is underway Sunday
followed a now familiar ritual an
unauthorized March that began peacefully
many of the protesters wore face masks
in defiance of a recently introduced ban
a mass show of disobedience so don't
think that the movement is slowing down
in fact it is growing strong and
stronger banners outlined their five
demands including more political reform
and warnings that Hong Kong was becoming
a police state among the sea of familiar
flavor
Catalonians to police this was an
illegal assembly and the operation to
ended lasted into the night Adrian Brown
al-jazeera Hong Kong